I paid $100 to look at a stranger's junk
whoa you can buy a junk drawer off of
ebay it's just somebody's random junk if
they have accumulated most people have a
junk drawer in their house it's a lot of
really weird random things I bought two
different junk drawers off eBay in case
one of them sucks this junk drawer was
114 dollars which is an insane amount to
pay this one was 65 95
oh my god what's up with this giant
pencil always a giant novelty pencil how
much do you think someone would pay for
the stuff that's in your drawer probably
like five bucks and I look in your
drawer
voodoo doll this is a pillow I cross
stitch this is Satan 666
do you think someone would pay like a
hundred and fourteen dollars sure what
you have in your drawer oh no John are
you doing that we're gonna see if we can
find out anything interesting about
somebody based on what kind of junk
they've accumulated let's open up the
slightly less expensive junk drawer some
of this looks like fancy junk whoa
okay this is a wooden box and it's very
heavy and there's a real cool deer on
the cupboard
Oh God I thought it was locked and I was
gonna feel like an idiot if I got mailed
a locked box that I couldn't open
there's a lot of job oh okay we have a
pipe
we got a baggie of coins oh my god I'm
so gonna wear this this is a bolo tie
there's a horse on it
my secret desire to be a cowboy is about
to be fulfilled whoa whoa a pocketknife
and for knifing what is this I can't
tell what it's made out of but it's
getting all over me the face is so scary
nightmare bear I feel like it's looking
at me it's like kind of broken Oh God
this lighter says dad on it I've got
your dad's lighter this is the weirdest
coin I have ever
it says Zeus summons the gods of Olympus
what is this something that you shoot
out of a gun if babies drank beer I feel
like they would drink this baby beer JJ
back-row container with a very old-timey
man on the front this is the last thing
that came in this 65 95 bucks of junk I
don't know what this is I can't tell if
this is authentic or not but this is an
old whiskey bottle it says Jack Daniel
on it but I feel like this is the junk
drawer of an old timey grandfather
cowboy man I guess I have more knives
now than I did when I started so that's
exciting
I wish I had worn gloves to go through
this because now my hands are super
grimy with old timey grime it's not a
great feeling on to the next junk this
was the more expensive junk drawer at
114 dollars so let's see what a hundred
and fourteen dollars worth of junk looks
like ah okay this freaked me out because
there's just like a crumpled-up body
this smells so musty this is the
hunchback of notre damn doll this was
like this in the box oh it just looks
like a headless doll so there's these
two purple mouse things and they feel
very dirty and old they are so musty
incense oh okay this smells bad it
smells like a perfume counter at a
department store which to me is not
super relaxing this is an artist's
rendering of a football I don't
understand what this is this is the
fanciest dolphin I've ever seen this is
most representative of what you find in
a junkyard
cords we have a plastic coffin that's
his r.i.p on it this is a fun toy for
children to playing with I don't know
this is a bracelet that doesn't quite
close I may be broke this this is a
flashlight that says the amazing live
sea monkeys on it so this is a sea
monkey themed flashlights ooh a
membership card to the Oasis casino in
Nevada I just looked it up this casino
doesn't exist anymore it was demolished
in 2013 host casino membership after
going through the more expensive junk
drawer I'm gonna be honest I like kind
of don't care who this person was
it really just reminds me that chunk is
terrible one man's junk is another man's
junk I feel like somebody took this and
they held it up and their life does this
give me joy absolutely not which is
understandable this doesn't give me joy
either I feel happy that these people
found a way to get rid of their junk now
all I want to do is just get all the
junk out of my life
I just super want to go wash my hands
right now do you have a junk George I
did I just went through it and then I
put it in the trash where it belongs so
I was drunk in it but it's my junk but
should I think this how the trash would
sell it on eBay yeah